man how do you deal with um coming at it
getting through cancer and then having
to deal with just a whole nother hurdle
obviously you got you know stuff in your
personal life going on as well you know
you you're you it just you know you got
to have some mental fortitude to really
get on the other side of a battle with
cancer well the defective thing is that
that lawsuit started as soon as I got
sick so that was so they were both
happening at the same time yeah like
when I found out I was sick it kind of
conversations kind of happened when I
was knee-deep in chemo and I was really
really really sick this ain't a sympathy
card at all just like yo people can
relate to what it feels like being sick
and thinking you're gonna die and also
having threats of your business being
taken almost like it was on purpose hey
man wild timing on their end right right
maybe they didn't plan it that way but
that's the way it worked out and so it
was kind of tough but like it really put
everything in perspective for me I'm
like well first of all I really gotta
stick around right like I'm really not
gonna have to I can't go nowhere now and
it's really really made me realize like
the good precious moments like you know
with a pure things outside of business
and so
you know for me that's why the Cubs that
Forbes cover felt good coming out of
that [__] it was like man I'm being
recognized I'm getting my flowers while
I'm here that's why the ad age award the
Cleo award these are all big you know
big
[__] globally recognized platforms
that are recognizing what we're doing
and so it just was the motivation I
needed to keep fighting but cancer was
really really hard on me I had major
PTSD from that [__] and I'm noticing
more and more people getting colon
cancer at a young ass age and it's just
scary bro it's just like really really
like a lot of men don't go and get
checked for that [__]
no because the symptoms are so I had
zero symptoms I had early stage three
colon cancer that means another six
months of letting that ride would have
took my ass out so I probably would have
had a year or so if I would have waited
six months or more to even get checked I
probably would have had a year or two
years at most the hardest thing for me
to watch was like the the brother you
know the shout out to his whole family
um his kids and his wifey but you know
seeing the inky boys go through that we
found out at the same time you know what
I mean and
I'm just like damn bro like that [__]
hurt and it hit hard because I'm like
damn not everyone's gonna have a chance
to make it through this and so I just
take a lot more calmer approach on life
and like stress and I just I feel
blessed to even be here bro and that's
why I try to tell people when people get
stressed out about money and things
that's going on but today's world of my
bro like yeah [__] stuff but you're
alive man like you can't you can't even
downplay how big that is right now for
sure brother that is I think that some
people forget that what was the um like
what made you get tested for for it was
it just like a normal run-of-the-mill
doctor's visit nah because I was with
the doctor already that wouldn't even
have ever looked for that it was like
some weird like Universal gut feeling I
I just had I just woke up one day was
looking out my window my damn I actually
got a good life here things are going
good I'm successful I feel like cookies
is going to be something incredible
that's going to live forever like what
am I actually missing in life that where
am I missing at I'm like
maybe Health like I'm you know I'm
losing a little weight I'm not as big as
I used to be but maybe I should like get
myself a private doctor to really look
into what I got going on because you
know I just want to make sure I'm good
it's crazy because five years before
this I had a fear of having a stomach
cancer like my mom I went and got a
colonoscopy 100 clean wow so five years
so in five years in five years that
cancer developed and got to early stage
three and so
I picked a random ass up I picked a
random ass day that called my partner
Parker and asked him do we know any
concierge doctors any private doctors
that could actually care about me as a
human or really looking at me and we
found a doctor that was not only you
know willing to take me home but he's
also investor into our business and he's
the only doctor in the country that does
his test the gallery test so when I went
to go see him he was like yo we can run
you know all your blood work and make
sure you're good but like this new test
came out two months ago I want to run on
you and test for cancer for 50 types of
cancer student blood I'm like let's run
it and that's how you found this [__]
and
the article came out like maybe like
three weeks ago I'm kind of like one of
the first people that publicly took that
test found Thai head cancer addressed it
and made it through the situation so
there's a big debate about this test
right now not a lot of doctors want to
take it on because
false positives that's the craziest [__]
I've ever heard in my life I saw it work
for me it saved me that's why I'm here
right now and I appreciate about this
every time I get a chance that that test
should be available I mean it feels like
an easy test to take too like in terms
of like what do you think like yeah it's
a blood test blood test and I would
rather get a false positive and think
I'm going to have cancer for a week and
a half until they go look inside my body
and then find out that I'm good right
then like not know anything at all yeah
because you got doctors that are doctors
are I mean man you got good doctors you
got doctors who are just getting a check
it's like teachers I look at doctors and
teachers kind of it's like anything in
business it's doctor being a doctor's
business and you know some of the
institutions like even though they're
good doctors they just don't have the
bandwidth like if you're at Kaiser
Permanente you're seeing 4 000 patients
right how could you actually truly keep
up with one of those patients facts like
even if you're a really good person even
if you don't have a hidden agenda
yeah you can't your bandwidth is going
to be done you're not gonna be able to
keep track of every and so you know for
all my people out there with money that
got money that care about their health
you know the new flex is getting
concierge doctor okay yeah all the rad
cats out there living fast on the road
not eating so well like
yo [__] that Gucci belt [__] that [__]
that new whip you know [__] [__] that
new chain [__] get yourself a
concierge doctor make sure you pay
attention to your health that's the new
flex really